Becky says how do I talk to my
significant other about my debt and the
steps I'm taking to get out of it now
Travis I imagine quite a bit you'll see
folks who were one person and a couple
is really interested it's the biggest
reason for divorce man yeah documentary
- yeah like money is the number one
reason for divorce it's a big problem I
we had a screening in London a couple of
weeks ago and a young man came up to me
almost in tears after watching the film
because it triggered for him what was
going on in his own relationship and
that disconnect between husband and wife
or partner and partner you know can be
very very difficult to navigate you know
you got to take a case by case one of
the things that's been amazing about
doing this film is that it's it's
stripping away the taboo around money
Americans most people in America I
should say feel a lot of shame around
money mm-hmm and this question is very
sorry this question this question is
very much around the topic of shame
because she doesn't want it's a girl
yeah it's Becky Becky Becky doesn't want
to tell her partner that she's in debt
you know that that that's a shameful
thing to have to face so I don't know
you know it's funny like doing this film
like reminds me of like coming out like
the way that a lot of people talk to me
about being liberated by this
information it's as if they've come out
of the closet in some way where they're
like relinquishing their shame yeah and
I think it's very liberating and so I
would encourage her to to take the step
because you're gonna know more about
yourself you're gonna know more about
your relationship you're gonna know more
about your partner right and since it's
the person you're living with apparently
yeah you want to know everything you can
about that person yeah it probably is I
need to come up on the first date you
know you have hi I'm Becky I have
$65,000 worth of student debt right but
I also think that you can speak about it
in a nuanced way as well you can say hey
part of this is because I made some ear
respond
simple choices with money before and I'm
making really good choices with my money
now here's how I'm making decisions now
here's how I'm working to pay off the
debt and I think quite often people
really respect that and when I first
started dating my wife she was just the
tail-end of paying off some student debt
and and for her you know that was a good
decision at the time she actually ended
up not needing the the degree that she
got ultimately from that but lay at the
time it was a good decision a good good
decision for that period of her life and
so some of this debt might be well I
felt like it was a good decision at the
time but in retrospect of course I had a
ball Swansea said hindsight is 50/50
what yeah Jim Harr one of my favorite
people on earth did he just get a he
deems wrong and he mixed up his idiom
but I think it's a more profound idiot
way like like hindsight is 50/50 like
yeah actually I made a mistake I thought
it was good a good decision at the time
but it's a 50/50 shot of being right or
a 50/50 shot of being wrong that's great
so so I think that with Becky there's a
responsible way to put this forward with
someone if they're new in your life then
there's a time to bring this up it's
before you move in together it's before
you start sharing finances but there's a
way to tackle this to have the
conversations to set them up for the set
expectations for the relationship and I
think it's important here's how I want
to spend money because if you're setting
expectations for someone what you're
saying there is here's I plan to live in
this life together with you I want to
make sure we're on the same page going
forward so we can spend our money
responsibly yeah yeah that could be a
conduit to explore what's valuable for
each person in the relationship one of
the scenes in the documentary does that
they they do a top 10 list how do they
like just what are the top 10 ways that
they want to spend their time and money
I love how Taylor when she was like
listening on her top 10 things like none
of it really involved money no it was
great
and and and most people will find that
to be true you list out your top five
favorite things or top ten favorite
things that really make you tick or make
you happy and money is is not the number
one dry
to make those things happen yeah I often
think that that yeah we can't buy
happiness but sometimes we can buy
things that augment our life that
enhance our experience of life and
that's ultimately how you can be a good
steward of your money is will this serve
a purpose well bring joy will augment
will it enhance will it amplify my life
if so and I can afford it that's another
that's another key there is being able
to afford it and not just monetarily
yeah yeah and not just the the price tag
yeah yeah I could spend $100 on this
widget but can I afford to take care of
the thing water the thing change the
tires on the thing whatever it is right
you